hello freak [ __ ] yeah I'm dying to
tell you this story about about my dad
okay so when I was 12 moved to Toronto
right living in Canada dad was the
president of Nabisco Canada and I was
speaking of headbang I was a [ __ ]
rabid Motley Crue fan right I [ __ ]
love Motley Crue's this was 1987 shout
of the dough right now this is their
girls girls girls tour right I mean I
got [ __ ] Motley Crue all over my
bedroom walls I'm [ __ ] crazy about
these [ __ ] guys now they come to to
Toronto for their girls girls girls tour
they're doing Maple Leaf Gardens and the
day before the contrary I should say my
dad knew that what a big fan I was and
the biscuit Canada had a skybox in the
arena but my dad also knew that that
nobody from Nabisco gave a [ __ ] about a
Motley Crue concerts the skybox was
going to be empty so then my dad said to
me he said hey I know how much you love
Miley crew and so I'm gonna bring you to
the concert we can sit in the Nabisco
skybox and I tell my dad dad watching
Motley Crue through a plate glass window
sucks he says alright well you know
basically [ __ ] you you know he's like if
you can do better than then we'll do
better
you know what use your tickets if you
can did you know I'm [ __ ] and I was
13 you know right so the day before the
concert and I see on the news they're
like complains there's like these
[ __ ] [ __ ] rock stars come to our
city and [ __ ] me [ __ ] around like one
way or another and I'm like dude they're
here the [ __ ] what would you say
Rockstar yeah they made the news for it
some like Bush I forget what it was I
think they started some kind of fire it
said something great but they were on
the news you know and they're like oh
they were complaining these [ __ ] guys
come here okay and so I'm like they're
in Toronto they're in the city now and
the [ __ ] concerts tomorrow so I
deduce that they're in a hotel and I'm
gonna [ __ ] find these guys I'm gonna
[ __ ] hear 13 I was 13 and so I go
[ __ ] running to my room right it's
like right away I'm thinking I know all
the guys and I know their real names
like Vince Neil is Vincent Wharton right
like I know other names I'm like thank
you [ __ ] check into the hotel as like
ranked carlton Ferran oh right that's
Nikki Sixx they're not gonna use the
real names and I was like they're gonna
check into the hotel under the name of
their manager right and I just guess I
just knew it go right into my room and I
[ __ ] check on my little Cosette
[ __ ] album sleeves I check every one
it says Doc McGhee which was their
manager I Doc McGhee so I'm like that's
the [ __ ] one I could run into the
phone book and the you know I'd [ __ ]
open it up to hotel like the yellow
pages and I just drink charcoal and
every [ __ ] hotel in the yellow pages
and when the hotel answers I'm like will
you please put me through to mr. doc
McGee's room right and the [ __ ] show
was like a Sunday so it's a Saturday and
my dad's like watching college football
right I'm sitting out on the phone call
and every [ __ ] hotel in Toronto just
going down the list not even calling the
ones with the ads like literally just
sticking to the list so I don't miss one
and my mom's pissed because there was no
call waiting she's like you're tying up
the house phone my dad all my dad ever
wanted was for me to show initiative and
to be like motivated for something you
know and so my dad's like super stoked
I'm on fire I'm telling my mom mom I'm
called Motley Crue [ __ ] and and my
dad like calls off my mom you know like
honey like let him do his thing
and I [ __ ] sat there for probably 2
or 3 hours just calling her hotels and I
get they put me through to this room
there was one like false alarm you know
but then the second Magee's room that I
got through to the guy picks up the
phone and I said hello is that Doc
McGhee and he says no this is Doc's
brother Scott he's and I'm like as in
motley crue and he says he says how did
you get this number and I told him I
[ __ ] I just call it every [ __ ] hotel
in the yellow page I just never told
them I said I just caught every Hotel in
the yellow pages is the crew there and
and he goes he goes what like hold on a
second are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's that's awesome and he says he
goes I'm so impressed by what you did he
says he says how would you like if I put
you on the list for backstage passes and
I can I can give you tickets in the
fifth Road so he gave me two tickets in
the fifth row [ __ ] backstage passes
my dad with my went [ __ ] chauffeur
my dad's chauffeur to the [ __ ] Maple
Leaf Gardens then we've gotten the
[ __ ] press line or the [ __ ] bit for
fifth road and say yeah that's actually
better than the first row a little back
was the dopest I was [ __ ] head bang
like a mod to get myself hella
brain-damaged that picture from the did
like how are you not showing me with
[ __ ] nikki sixx and Tommy leaves that
you were picture no no no no but Google
Stevo and [ __ ] Stevo and Motley Crue's
man man you were 13 was I was [ __ ] 13
we went up to the skybox and I put my
ghetto blaster so I put my ghetto
blaster next to the little speaker deal
yeah there's me and Tommy Lee and then
it's my how old is Tommy Lee oh my god
that's crazy I mean Nikki Sixx right
there
you were like a baby I was a [ __ ]
baby dude that is so weird yeah and you
know I'm standing next to these guys and
I'm like I don't have [ __ ] you know
like [ __ ] to talk to them about but the
fact that I was standing next to those
guys and I was like you know what I'm
here backstage with my [ __ ] heroes
and it's because I [ __ ] decided so
you know like there's something about
that that gave me this this mentality
and then you see like top left right
there
check it out [ __ ] all these years
later [ __ ] when they when they
announced that they're back together and
going on their Carnival of sins to her
Tommy Lee asked me to do something
[ __ ] up and introduced them dude how
full-circle
yeah dude that's crazy dad it was the
dopest who's the dude on the far right
that's Mick Mars dude with the hat yeah
he's got like a herd of bone disease
what's going on with them yeah like I
forget what it's called but yeah he's
like they gotta like have him come out
when the lights aren't on oh my god you
know maybe he's doing better and he
limps he's my shape poor guy I love that
story
Wow and my dad you know I was like my
kind of how my dad is
that's awesome man yeah that's a great
story thank you man it made it really
made me into a monster and some regard
because like I think that at that young
age it's like you know I I really can
[ __ ] you know if you just have
I said like doesn't matter what people
want it just matters how bad they've
really put them on it I mean of course
they it definitely matters what they
want you want to play basketball against
well of course within something but I
want it right within [ __ ] parameters
of reality factor what do they say they
say that that luck is when preparation
meets opportunity
yes which is dope I love I love that
[ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
[Music]